there's no doubt that the Internet is
creating what is called an intelligent
planet that is the skin of the planet
Earth is becoming a network by which
intelligent creatures communicate with
each other but that's just the first
step
some people think that the next step in
the coming decades is not going to be
the Internet it's going to be brain net
because we're at the point now where we
can actually connect computers to the
living mind in fact I was just at
Berkeley a few weeks ago where I had a
demonstration of this we can actually
create videos of your thoughts these
videos are not perfectly accurate but I
saw a demonstration at a laboratory at
Berkeley where you can actually see in a
video screen what people are thinking
so with electrodes perhaps or EEG
sensors in a helmet connected to our
brain perhaps one day we'll be able to
have brain to brain communication and
that me gives us the possibility of
brain net in fact some of the leading
neurologists doing these experiments
have serious proposed a brain net
whereby you would exchange not just
information like typing but also
emotions feelings because these are also
part of the fabric of our thoughts and
then what comes beyond that well of
course beyond that is science fiction
and science fiction gives us all sorts
of horror stories of things like Skynet
maybe one day the internet will become
sentient maybe one day the internet will
think that humans are in the way and
perhaps the internet will take over just
like in the Terminator series well I
don't think so the Internet is simply a
way in which minds can communicate with
other minds we see no self-awareness in
the internet now some people say well
what about some kind of collective
consciousness that arises by an emergent
phenomenon well that's a lot of
gobbledygook that's a lot of nice words
maybe maybe not but it's pure
speculation at the present time even in
the laboratory with our finest
instruments and the latest developments
in artificial intelligence we cannot
make a
computer become self-aware you realize
that one of our most advanced computers
was the IBM computer Watson which
defeated two humans on the the program
Jeopardy at that point many pundits said
oh my god the end is near
the robots are gonna put us in zoos
they're gonna throw peanuts at us make
us dance behind bars when they take over
just like we make bears dance behind
bars today well just remember that once
and no matter how fast it is we're so
stupid you couldn't congratulate it you
can't go up to Watson slap its
transition to say good boy you just beat
two humans on Jeopardy you made history
let's drink to it you see Watson is an
adding machine a very sophisticated
adding machine it has billions of times
faster than the human brain but that's
all it is it's what it's called an
expert system it deals with formalized
inputs formalized outputs you talk to an
expert system every time you're on the
telephone and the telephone says please
hit button one please hit number two for
the next option that's called an expert
system it's basically a sophisticated
adding machine that sounds like it's
thinking but it's not it's simply using
a formalized logic if you hit one then
you go there if you hit two you go
someplace else
that's Watson of course on a very very
sophisticated level so I personally
think that we don't have to worry that
the internet is going to become sentient
you